ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are recording this
on january 22nd friday
uh my birthday i'm 17 years old
and i really have to start taking life
seriously now you know i spoke to my
parents and
we're going to look at colleges and
we're very excited uh
and just everything you know the future
is bright and i have my entire life
ahead of me
you know uh i put up on my instagram
uh the [__] pig photo
from a sketch i did years ago
okay look at that eli roth happy
birthday to q very fun
uh i put that up and i said
today is my birthday i want to thank my
parents for all their support this is
what you created enjoy it
and my aunt
wrote a comment and the comment let's
not find it
and the comment was and my cousin sent
me the comment my con the comment was
the saddest part is that you have your
grandfather's name
and you don't care at all and you care
nothing about his legacy
very very nasty comment very very nasty
comment
and you know me i hate to bring
family drama on the show i hate that
you know i don't do it we can get this
down
i i really don't do it okay uh my aunt
kathleen
by the way okay uh
comes from me on instagram
brings up my grandfather and insults me
on the day of my birth
now let's get something straight you bum
[__]
didn't you fake a drug overdose
didn't you fake a suicide attempt i
keenly remember
you faking that you overdosed on drugs
and you were taken to a hospital in an
ambulance
in front of your mother who had just
dealt with grandpa's death
what part of grandpa's legacy were you
honoring with that behavior
what part of it do you remember that i
remember you going to a hospital
and then having the entire family go
worried about you
not me but other people because i know
what you're up to you clown [__]
they went to the hospital and said what
drugs is she on doctor and the doctor
goes
there are no drugs in her system she
literally
pretended to be unconscious so then an
ambulance went to the home put her in it
and drove her to the hospital scaring
her mother half to death
grandpa's legacy okay what part of
grandpa's legacy
were you thinking about when you took
his money for law school and then never
practiced
law and were fired multiple times
by multiple law firms all over long
island because you're mentally ill
forcing uh your father to
set up a pretend law office for you in
your basement
that you pretend to be a lawyer in
you added a phone line to the house to
pretend
to be an attorney what part of the
legacy
is that what part of the legacy is
borrowing money
from your more successful brothers and
sisters
and not paying any of it back while you
sit around the house
doing percocet and drinking white wine
what part of the legacy is that
are you honoring his days as a carpenter
is that what you're honoring by sitting
around and getting junked up
on the couch pretending to ot and by the
way
the life you live you don't even have to
pretend okay
you can't even do that right so i'm just
wondering why you would bring up my
grandfather i have all the respect in
the world for a legendary character
patriarch of an amazing family rose from
poverty did all these things
why come on my instagram and say
anything negative
and and bring up a guy who every day
with your life and your choices where is
his legacy in mind kathleen and i know
you watch this
okay in between reading cue drops and
letting fox news
broil your already vicodin adult brain
okay it's the wrong day kathleen i'm the
wrong one you know that
i blocked you on the family uh i i got a
new phone
together the family [__] group text
because you kept texting people about
all the dishes they have to do when they
come to the family parties
[__] no one's coming anymore no one
cares i don't want to be near you
you should be in a padded room how my
mother is in an asylum and you have
somehow escaped it is beyond me
and it's beyond everybody you are a
disgrace
drug addict potentially closeted lesbian
you've never moved out of the house
nobody respects you you are a pedophile
probably
you are gross around kids nobody wants
you [__] taking baths with their
[__] kids
you're a [__] weirdo they gotta watch
you like [__] epstein
so don't f keep my name out of your
mouth okay pedophile drug addict
this is the fake business mug
and the fake business mug uh is is not
on sale anymore
oh it is for sale until the 28th yeah
i just thought it was a bit rude how she
came from me
brought up my grandfather said something
very nasty to me
i mean what part of my grandfather's
legacy do you honor by
not working this is a guy that worked
every day of his life
uh so you don't work you don't have a
family
you steal money you fake drug overdoses
you're a moral degenerate you you
you have no respect for people you drive
wedges in between people in the family
and you attack successful people in the
family my grandfather did
none of those things he was a devoutly
religious
incredibly generous brilliant hard
worker who raised an entire family
you are the exact opposite of all of
those things
all of those things okay every one of
them
i blocked you i got a new phone to get
out of the group chat
because i didn't want to deal with your
constant
terrorism or updating me like hey uh
little tom got his license who hey who
gives a [__]
dummy get a job get a [__] job i have
a
job why don't you get a job stop
worrying about who got their license
nobody wants you neither family
you [__] freak where's your man [__]
where's your woman where's anything what
are you doing
i mean let let's get real i mean this is
a woman who does nothing but
but attack attack attack and by the way
[__] my fam and i like some of them
but and then my aunt goes like this uh
she goes like this she goes
she goes oh you know if i bump she's
told this to somebody else because if i
bumped into him
i'd really give him a piece of my mind
how are you gonna bump into me [__] i
don't live in your kitchen
okay you've never left you've never left
home
i'm in malibu oh how am i gonna bump
into you
okay buying tampax at the local cvs
for your barren childless vagina how
would we ever bump heads together
keep my name out of your mouth
scumbag you're a degenerate
you're a moral this isn't even a podcast
anymore
i'm talking directly to you you are a
failure
and a moral degenerate okay
come pig from a sketch a few years ago
on my chest
is a funny dumb joke you my friend
are a disgusting nightmare
that nobody wants to be around you're a
thief you've stolen people's money
haven't you kathleen you've stolen money
haven't you
you know you have where's the money
kathleen
did you take it you took all the money
didn't you
and then you go cry some people have
family be like you're being too hard on
her
[__] you too hey [__] you
too you think i give a [__] about any of
you [__]
you [__] i have a family okay
it's joe rogan and candace owens my
mother and father
give a [__] about you [__] clowns go
do a [__] irish step dance
i don't give a [__] this [__] is out of
her
[__] mot you are out of your mind
just bring in my grandfather my
instagram trying to trying to knock me
like that
it's a shitty thing to do especially
from you
who's accomplished
in your entire [__] life so
that's kind of how i wanted to start off
the show because i just and it's not the
whole show but i just want to
you know get it out in the open the way
that i feel about this woman
uh who's who just every opportunity she
she
tries to neg me and she does it on a
public forum
and i will do it now on a public forum
too so i apologize and i
i would be worried that you'd sue me but
you don't know how to practice
law you're not a real lawyer are you
because you work from a basement and you
have pretend clients
you set up a care bear you had from when
you were [__] nine and you still have
because you never left your house
and you go hello mr care bear did you
have a dewey
well let's look at your options you're a
clown [__]
no one takes you seriously you should be
getting electroshock therapy
[__] if it was a years ago you'd be
rosemary kennedy
you'd have your and i know i know i'm
not making fun of mentally ill but my
mother's a [__] nut and i know who
these people are
and i know that your boyfriend donald
trump's out of office now and trust the
plan never happened and
you know you couldn't storm the capitol
because it's too far away from the
[__] house you've never left
um you're you're a joke to everyone so
if you come on my page again
i'm just gonna do this again i'm just
gonna keep reminding the hundreds of
thousands of people that listen to me
some of whom who may know you what an
absolute scumbag you are
and how much of a disgusting pig you
continue to be
for this all this time so keep going at
me
please please
uh other than that i feel good i'm
excited about the year
uh i'm excited about i i think the
important things in life are friends and
family which is ironic because we just
did that
but i feel like i i love the people in
my life and that's so great and i think
that many of you right now
have family members maybe not like mine
you know disgusting you know pedophile
uh degenerates uh but um
but some of you are like hey man
i feel this way about a family member
tell them
tell them get them out of your life let
2021 be the year of [__] it
you can't it's not all about trump
anymore it's not all about politics
let's go back to hating the people you
know
hating the people you have a reason to
you know my other aunt who i love my
aunt donna called me she goes
you know biden got inaugurated me and my
husband were out we were bird watching
we saw hawk and i'm like oh that zest
for life
you could have had it the last four
years you let someone rob you of that
you sat and watched cnn before you
couldn't they were birds
there were birds the hawks were in the
trees
you could have watched it for four years
but instead you're like no i want to
just key into this
not literally nothing has changed i mean
nothing nothing from trump to biden
really
in a span of hours very little has
changed by and signed some executive
orders which is great
you know i would prefer if he signed an
executive order to put my aunt a mental
institution
but we're still waiting on that we're
still petitioning but i mean do you
think i i went a little too far but i
don't think so you have a great amount
of respect for your grandfather you've
talked about him endlessly yeah and it's
just a [__] up thing to say
it's a very [__] up thing to say on
the day of my birthday
you know it's a very [__] up thing to
say um
you know especially from some weird
sexually dysfunctional degenerate thief
drug addict
that's all what did jordan peterson say
clean your room
clean your room clean your room
kath think i care
think i give a [__] where am i gonna
bump into you dummy
brentwood beverly hills okay
i live in a 190 million dollar estate in
beverly hills
you stupid [__]
are you dumb i paid 190 million dollars
bitcoin for an estate that i live in
in bentley rolls-royce village
bentley heights
he's laughing so he doesn't even know
where the [__] it is because he's dumb
and poor
i live in rolls-royce's stan
[Laughter]
and you don't you live at home her whole
life is like an after-school special
that went incredibly wrong
you know my mother by the way here's a
fun story about her keep i hope you're
still listening
and by the way kathleen i hope this
doesn't affect your ability to buy the
ridge wallet which is
a great compact wallet where you could
keep
uh the card of a real attorney and uh
your debit card which your parents pay
for your 50.
um my mother she was like kind of a
ballerina back back in the day she like
tried to do things before she had a
mental break
and my mother saw her once like
backstage at a show like after she
and she was just like chugging a bottle
of booze she was 12. oh really yeah
she's like 12 or 13.
she's like hitting a bottle of booze so
again again
hey clean it up clean it up
okay thanks the irish are discussed
let's be very honest about the irish
lots of problems lots of problems with
the irish
i love them i am them lots of issues
clean it up please clean it up it's the
wrong thing to say
and i think what i did was a
proportional response i didn't want to i
didn't want to be too
um i didn't want to be too crazy about
it
you know goku oh you're gonna go tell my
stepmother
and my daddy you're gonna go cry
i don't care i don't care go get all of
them on your side
go tell them all that timmy said a bunch
of mean things you think i give a flying
[__]
dummy i'm trying to get arab money
jew money not [__] potato farmer
[__] money think i give a [__] you
tell a bunch of cops
and a bunch of [__] storytelling mix
that you don't like me you could all sit
around hard
go away go away i have a new name
tim muhammad
[Laughter]
stein cohen i am tim muhammad steincohn
do you understand me i yes i have light
skin
yes i have rosacea yes i have eczema yes
something that looks like maybe plaque
psoriasis yes i have
skin flakes yes i have i'm a drug addict
yes
i have many problems that would
associate me with the irish
but i am converting to both islam and
judaism
in los angeles tim muhammad steincohn
that is my name i am a muslim and i am a
jew
i am on the corner i i am i am on the
west bank i have one foot
with the rock throwers and one foot with
the uh
colonizers you see just straddling
just straddling that because i i've left
i'm leaving the irish
because i'm i'm i'm sick of them this
isn't lord of the rings
a little sick of it but anyway that's my
we have so much else to cover uh on the
program but that's my
opening and the only reason i do that is
the only reason i do that is i want the
best for her
yes i want the best for her and this is
what people don't understand
so many people are unwilling to take uh
criticism
and what i just did there was i
delivered some criticism
because i feel like if she takes it
um and we will you know probably hear
from attorneys
[Laughter]
then now man ben refreshes his email
like this like
oh boy who is it today is it at the
airbnb
people is it this one is it that one but
we have a great first amendment attorney
um and i believe that i should be able
to say what i want to say and i believe
that other people should be able to say
what they want to say
so have at it kathleen or whoever but
um yeah i mean at the end of the day
some of you know really what i'm saying
uh about this woman is that i felt her
comment was inappropriate
i felt her comment was inappropriate and
i felt her behavior
in life doesn't really suggest the type
of stable human being
that should be critiquing me who's gone
out and just tried to make
people chuckle i just want to make
people
laugh i'm not trying to put them in jail
didn't you work with the da's office for
a while just putting people in jail
giving people deweys and you would just
drive drunk to that job
didn't the irony ever get to you that
you were a drug addict putting other
drug addicts in jail just because they
were black or brown
didn't that arnie ever get to you you
thought you remember the department of
homeland security
because you had to go through some
background check
to do some job what did you do again
provide
legal cover so that the fbi could
torture 16 year old iraqi kids
try to find out where their parents were
how do you sleep at night
and i don't want you to kill yourself
after hearing all this because we know
you won't we know you'll just fake it
like he did last time like you did last
time
and people wanted to grab you out of
that bed you were laying in pretending
to be dead
they wanted to grab you and kill you so
anyway
i have a new family tim can you inquire
about legally changing my name to tim
mohamed stein cohen
absolutely thank you thank you
because i'm i'm trying to reconnect with
my persian roots
i want to be a persian i want to be a
persian i want to be a jeweler
i don't i i hate this i mean everyone's
too emo i was talking to
devon the other night and we were kind
of talking about that
like people are so emo now that
sociopaths get a bad rap
they really do people that can can
compartmentalize their emotions
everyone's like that's just so simple
but i've never heard the word sociopath
more than i've heard it in the last
few years always being leveled at people
by absolute [__]
who can't control their emotions at all
sociopath that guy is a sociopath
why because they don't cry and [__] and
moan all the goddamn time
who cares you know is that what a
sociopath is
is that a sociopath okay i don't
understand
i i look at so many men especially that
are just completely
fragile fall apart ice castles
ready to melt what about that is good
what about that is what we want as a
society both men and women
uh and women are now told they should be
sociopaths yes
be a girl boss and step on his neck
but men are being told that any uh you
know
whether they exhibit any signs of
aggression or any signs of like
competitiveness
they're uh psychotic and it's toxic it's
toxic but if a woman does it she's a
boss [__] i don't feel that's a
sustainable way forward
let everybody be a boss [__] let
everybody let everybody go out there
and compartmentalize a little bit you
can't fall down all the time
and go you know just just be like i just
can't even you have to reign it in
be a little tougher you know what i mean
you know
i mean my tirade this morning was was
is entertaining sure and there's a lot
of it all of it really that's true
and i don't mean she's a pedophile i'm
not saying she's a pedophile just you
don't want her near your cat i mean just
be real
uh let's just be real you just don't you
just don't this is a woman who gave me a
uh
a lecture about smoking a cigarette that
i shouldn't smoke while smoking
so this is the cognitive dissonance that
operates in her drug-addled brain
um so i mean again this is just i just i
just think we need
to you know go back to a time when we
can respect each other and love each
other
and uh walk in the light of christ
and i just feel like when you're making
a comment on my come pick instagram post
and it is not
nice you were not walking in the light
of christ
okay are you bringing out my grandfather
you're bringing up words like like
what's your legacy going to be
by the way have you thought about that
one
have you thought about your legacy do
you have any understanding
of the way you're viewed while you're
here can you imagine
what people will have the freedom to say
when you're not here
i mean wow but people like her live
forever
they live forever and torture everyone
it's true people like that my friend's
father was a great guy who i love but
drugs and never had a job and
you know cheated on the wife and
whatever maybe smacked or whatever but
you know i said to my friend one day i
said yeah it's gonna be sad when he
passes on he goes he'll never die
he goes he's had no stress in his life
because he's had no actual stress
he just doesn't care about anything and
people like that live forever just
torturing everyone around them
kind of interesting but i still like the
guy a lot
that's the point you know the point is
that we must
kind of coexist together and not lash
out
um and that's why i'm very disappointed
about what i did the first 20 minutes of
the show i'm not going to edit it out
i'm not going to edit it out because i
believe in freedom and fairness
and i i want to take accountability for
my actions
so i can't edit it out i cannot edit
the 20 minutes of truth that i started
the broadcast with today even though i
want to
i won't do it because i have too much
respect
for myself and i have to learn from this
i have to
grow and be better and change so by
listening to this and by letting
hundreds of thousands of people listen
to it
and play it and replay it and cut it up
into clips and put it out on instagram
and twitter
and facebook and hopefully get it
kicking on some reddits and spread all
over the dark web perhaps
uh i feel like we will all grow and
learn and i will not be able to ever
like
not see those words i will really be
like oh i'm so dis i'm so disappointed
in myself
that i said all of that and if i'd
edited it out
or ignored her comment i would never
have the learning experience that i'll
have now
by releasing this episode cutting it up
into clips plugging it on social media
trying to get people to retweet it
at potentially tagging you know her alma
mater and you know any place she may
have worked
and the reason i do that is because i
want to be accountable
for my set do you understand absolutely
it's accountability
it's truly accountability and i'm sorry
that you showed up for an episode you
got a family fight
i'm sorry about that many of you have
good families where you'll love each
other
my family is a bunch of like look a bog
farmer
bog farmer yeah i don't know what that
is but i think that's what they are
is that a real thing what is a bog look
up what a bog
is fog what is a bog
to cause to sink into or as if into a
bog
impede meyer usually used with down a
car
that oh yeah a car that has gotten
bogged down in the mud easy to get
bogged down in the details
yeah but isn't there something a bog is
bog a real word
what is bog in english slang maybe
that's what i'm using maybe so
let's see its origins are somewhat
unclear but a bog is another word for a
toilet
there you go well we've got it haven't
we and i love many
members of my family that are really
good people and i respect them and i
know that you know i'm very open about
my life and
that's not always comfortable for
everyone and i wish everyone the best
and i
it's about time to change the number
again that'll be happening next week
get on that get on the number change
uh it's time to change the old number
hopefully ahead of this episode being
released
i don't want to end up in another group
text she is going to hear this and she's
going to fly off the wall
she'll send it to everyone she'll be
like this is crazy i can't believe he
said this she'll
she'll really start
hey man hey man
we're just doing a little like business
don't be mad at me right
don't be mad at me i didn't do it
i didn't attack someone on their
birthday
on their instagram i didn't do it you
did it
you did it and that's unfortunate but
that's okay i don't i don't care anymore
about family party i will never now i
don't think i'll ever attend it
i don't think i can uh attend like
another family event i have to create a
new
film that's so exciting that's so
exciting
and it will be arabs and jews
arabs and jews people that own real
estate and people that sell
diamonds arabs and jews arabs and jews
they don't get along but they're not
cops and firefighters arabs and jews
arabs and jews they're not pigs with
flesh diseases
like my irish pig family
i will work for a persian or a jew
arabs and jews beverly hills
tanner pale i don't care
kind of cold do business with their
family
if you [__] over you're getting sued
i love arabs and jews
i wish i was an arab or a jew
i hate italians too
but i'm not one of those sauce monkeys
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
i have lots of that i don't have wi-fi
in a house i'm paying for
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
therapist betterhelp is a great service
it's
online counseling okay which is
everything right now is online
so go to betterhelp.com timd that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
you can join over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with an experienced professional
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide all over the world
so you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses
plus you can schedule a weekly video or
phone session so you won't ever have to
sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room with
additional therapy better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free
to change counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available i hope my aunt takes
advantage of this so many people are
using better help they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
okay there's a special offer for the tim
dillon show listeners you get ten
percent off your first month
at betterhelp.comd that's
betterhelp.comd
[Music]
penis is getting hard
bluetooth is made in the usa it's
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy and they prepare and ship it
right to you in a discrete package no
awkwardness you don't need
need to leave the house bluetooth brings
you the first chewable with the same fda
approved ingredients as viagra and
cialis it's great
everybody loves blue chew you take it
and your penis gets harder it stays hard
you can perform sexually that's
bluee2.com
bluee2.com promo code td
to try it free bluetooth is the better
cheaper choice and we thank you for
sponsoring the podcast remember
when you support our sponsors you help
make the podcast possible so please
use our promo code td at bluetooth.com
to get a hard penis
all right folks we are back the uh
this is recorded on two different days
just to break the illusion we don't want
to
do that but we have to we want to be
honest
and uh my my the first part of the
episode was recorded because i had
seen the instagram i had just seen the
instagram comment
and when ben walked in i was like yo
just get the studio ready we gotta go
let's go right now i've got things to
say you know i don't even remember what
i said but
you know i'm sure uh when it's
when it's live it'll be it'll be
something but who knows uh larry king
r.i.p
very sad 87 at la hospital three weeks
after being transferred
from the icu as he battled covet after
catching it from a health care worker
visiting his home
king has been married eight times to
seven different women
he's such a gangster why not
why not why not and not only why i mean
obviously there's always a reason
but i mean eight marriages i like the
idea that he just kept getting married
yeah
even though it like he just he still
liked the day
you know like he still wanted to have a
day
i like that you know we just podcasted
with lex friedman what a smart guy
asks great questions and the podcast was
good it was only
15 or 16 hours it's a nice uh
if you're taking a cross-country road
trip it's a great thing to listen to
all the way from new york to texas but
he's a great dude we really appreciate
him having us on
um and uh he said that i could lecture
at mit
he might set that up when coved ends
i could lecture at mit at that point
if i got the chance to do that i mean i
i mean
just spitting in the face of every
academic
who told me that i had to stay in school
and do my homework
spitting in the face of family members
that have said
similar things
uh the other day i tried to get a dog
i thought i was gonna get a dog first of
all i was gonna get a
spider we're gonna try to get a
tarantula and put a tarantula on the
desk even though
the studio is really good we're gonna
get this guy the goliath
bird eating spider it is the largest
spider in the world
it grows to the size of a dinner plate
um
it is really what it looked like yeah
it's very large and um
i called ben and i said i think we
should drive that to rancho cucamonga
where we found a spider dealer a
tarantula dealer
in an office building in rancho
cucamonga
and i did a science fair project on
spiders when i was a kid i find them
interesting i like that everyone else is
afraid of them they creep me out
too they creep you out because they have
the extra two legs
so they walk you know you know how it is
unlike an insect which is just gross a
spider is terrifying because really
the way it moves nothing really moves
like a spider
so that's what freaks people out um
[Music]
and i was thinking about getting a
spider
like true i mean this is the stage of
quarantine where we're starting to
really
come apart you know you probably notice
it out there in your own life you start
considering things that
you know were inconceivable
just 10 months ago especially in l.a i
mean things are open and i see people
out other
places but in la i mean it's still
really it's
it's shut down but hopefully that's
ending i don't even tell me to go to
austin i gotta go to austin
maybe i don't know but
we'll see joe rogan elon musk
first of all i'd go if somebody there
had any money
[Laughter]
um we sent elon the tesla rant
that i did yeah i emailed it it's all in
good faith it's all in good fun
it's all in good fun what did he tweet
he said uh something about comedy what
did he say
legalized comments comedy yeah how about
legalize
buying me a house rogan gives lex
friedman his watch lex friedman could
just make his own watch
hey why don't you give me something joe
you've given me a lot it's true but
i mean come on lex friedman gets a watch
from rogan how cool is that
right on the show rogan turns around and
this is a watch right here look at that
i was on rogan's podcast yesterday and
had on air one of the most special
moments of my life joe took off his very
favorite watch and gifted it to me to
have one of my heroes do that means more
than i can put into words
i'm not worthy but i'll work give me 200
on air in front of everyone give me 200.
i don't need your favorite watch give me
let me use your airbnb account
i'll pay just let me use your airbnb
account
we'll take care of it so we drive to
rancho cucamonga
to uh the spider room which i re let's
give a shout out to the spider room
the spider room in rancho cucamonga if
you are uh uh
looking for a spider here it is this guy
is the guy
wednesday through friday now we didn't
get a spider here but this guy is the
guy
yeah yeah um it had nothing to do with
him he was great
knowledgeable all of the spiders look
like they're well cared for
um you walk in this office building
and then it's like a regular
company yeah some i don't know what kind
of company it is
it looks like an office where i used to
sell mortgages just like a small
office and then in one of the rooms
there's just 200 venomous spiders
and this guy rents it out
you know your company's doing well when
you have to sublet one of the room one
of your conference rooms not even a
conference room
a small office to 200 venomous animals
but respect so we go there and we um
i go in there and exotic animal people
are odd they just
are i used to go see an anaconda get fed
at dj's reptiles in hicksville
uh long island they're odd the exotic
animal p
as you would imagine they're just
different something is
different about you if you are drawn to
snakes and spiders
usually things aren't going great
for the most part if you really get into
venomous animals
[Laughter]
you're not it's not this
very rarely do you walk into a reptile
shop and go
that guy's [__] gorgeous
like that doesn't happen it does that's
just not
the people you it's never like a
a six-pack malibu surfer
perfectly tan body shaggy blonde hair
big titted girlfriend and they're like
do you want to go to the beach today
and then [__] each other senseless or
do you want to go buy a madagascar
hissing cockroaches and
feed it to the spider i'm just saying
and i'm not you know i was gonna buy a
spider so i'm not
hey so we go in there it just seems like
most of the people
in the trade are
they're like the less successful joe
exotic
you know what i mean like they're not
they're not they don't they don't own a
zoo
right but whatever but it's it seems
like that's not an unfair thing to say
right people that are in there
there's something that you get drawn to
spiders yeah
but god god love them and i mean they've
got scorpions in there and
they've got brown widows brown widows
are like cousins of black widows and
insanely venomous yeah yeah it's
hilarious i said to the guy go like this
they go you know you wouldn't have like
brazilian wandering spiders or something
like that
which is like the most venomous spider
in the world and he goes
no and i was like he goes they all sold
out i'm like
you're selling brazilian wandering
spiders
in rancho cucamonga but god love but god
love the people that want to own
uh the most venomous spider in the world
that's a fun crew so i walked in there i
like to
peek into these worlds but i don't know
that i can i don't want to be in it
i just want to peer into it you know me
and ben walked in we almost got a
goliath i have the photo on my phone of
the spider we almost bought if you go
get my phone
yeah we could put it up i have despite
the picture of the spider and uh
we almost bought this spider and the guy
tells us he goes listen i got to be
honest because before you take this
thing home
i want to run through some housekeeping
with you i said okay
because it's going to flick microscopic
hairs at you which we know this is the
spider's defense mechanism and he goes
they're going to get in your throat and
your eyes
and he goes he goes they just got in my
eyes and throat and i said how long did
that last he goes nine days
i said nine days nine days so it just
flicks the microscopic hairs are getting
your throat your eyes it could be a real
problem
he also said the fangs are like three
quarter of an inch
they will pierce bone
this is very odd when you're about to
buy something for 175 dollars
and the thing that got me was he goes
you feed him one madagascar hissing
cockroach
a week even the the hairs and the bone
piercing
were getting to me but they weren't it
was when he said
you got to get cockroaches the big
hissing concrete
and the idea of just driving around in
my car with hissing cockroaches
in the back you've just made one
purchase and become another type of
person
like you've just spent 175 dollars
and literally become a totally different
human being
than the one you were before where
people start getting worried about you
like friends of mine would be worried
about me i'd be like oh yeah that's the
hissing cockroaches for the spider
they'd be like
hey man are you all right i thought
things were kind of good
i'm like no no things are great i'm just
in the spiders that can kill me
now that's what i like i like having a
tank full of spiders that could
kill me the goliath cannot kill you it's
venom is
you know potent to a degree but it's not
like a brazilian wandering spider or a
black widow
right brown widow uh we're trying to
figure out
speaking this but we thought we saw
brown recluse the other night in the
yard but then we went on google and
they're like they don't exist in
southern california
i was reading some forum and one guy is
my favorite thing my favorite thing is
just watching anonymous fights sometimes
and a doctor an entomologist you know a
specialist or whatever
you know or an invertebrate zoologist
whatever study spiders
the the guy goes hey man uh there are no
sp there's no brown recluses in
southern california there's a chilean
record there's just no brown recluses
and then uh one guy just right under
right under it goes hey
hey [__] you i was bitten woodland hills
that just made me laugh so hard
hey [__] you so we we don't know if
there are actually brown
recluses here or not i'm sure people
will will
now chime in and be like no i was bit by
but people are also idiots and i have no
idea like i'm sure people go in and go
is this a proud recluse bite and the
doctor goes that's a gunshot wound
you were shot like oh
but we walked out of the spider room and
we went to
uh puppy adoption because i said maybe
i'll get a puppy an animal shelter
an animal shelter which i gotta be
honest and this is a little
controversial i hear and i don't
uh uh i i it's i know that it's to help
them
and i want everyone to get help but it
is not a real
fun way to get a [__] dog is it
can we be honest these dogs are homeless
they're like four years old they're not
puppies
the people that are showing you the dogs
also look like they need a fair amount
of help
i mean it's just bad
and you sit there and they bring the dog
out and it's very sad because they
brought out a husky and
the husky's family returned them because
he was getting territorial with a baby
and uh they didn't have the time you
know people in l.a are so goddamn
selfish
they didn't have the time to throw
frisbee with the poor husky so they
brought him back it's [__] tragic
isn't it really sad it's very sad and
then they brought out a shepherd before
the husky and he and the gentle dog
they're beautiful dogs but they're aloof
and you could tell they've been through
it a little
yeah they've been through it a little
you know i tend to think of lady in the
[__]
you know where they come out of the like
a nice box and they pop out
on christmas morning you know they bring
out these like
damaged skittish dogs
and and i i immediately
try to be a little funny which they
don't like humor they hate humor these
people
she goes what are the important
qualities of a dog and i said one that
can swallow the most cocaine
that's funny what's wrong with her
this woman gives me a look i said i'm
kidding i'm a comedian
she goes oh i'm just joking
but i don't have the time to devote to a
puppy and it's sad
and um because i will here's the thing
about me i
know this is why i can't adopt anything
i will bring it back
like i'm the guy that brings it right
back
i'll bring it right back first sign of a
problem
i mean literally the first
sign of a problem i will show up and
they know that about me which is why
they make every dog sound horrible
every dog because they look at me they
go he's the guy that brings it back
dude every dog they were like it might
kill a baby i'm like i didn't even ask
that they just don't want me to adopt it
because they know like the first sign of
trouble i'm like
you're out of here i'll just
he's back i'll be like you had him for
six hours i'm like
the dog went crazy he got into something
but it's sad uh that
there are so many dogs out there
and they're not cared for but i can't
take on the responsibility of having a
dog
unless i have the time i'm gonna travel
a lot coming up we have new dates on the
road uh
all over the place we're in uh
pennsylvania and
baltimore maryland and we are in uh
chicago and we're in um
austin and we're in a bunch of other
places and the dates are on the website
and
the website's getting redone so we're
putting stuff
we're putting stuff up uh little by
little we're trying to get everything
out there but uh we're gonna be on the
road so i don't have the time to really
deal with a dog
i don't have the time to really devote
myself to
an animal and i gotta be honest with you
this is gonna sound horrible and i hate
admitting this
i want a purebred puppy
who's very cute and very happy
do you see what i mean is that
controversial to say
no but some people just get mad if then
you went to like a puppy mill or
something like what is a puppy mill
you know where they make the dogs you
know they
the dogs die they're they're all inbred
it's not good
it's really not good so you go to a
breeder yeah yeah
yeah they're breeding dogs they're using
them to to make money off of them
but a lot of times the living conditions
aren't that good and there's so many
dogs that need homes anyway
like and purebred dogs you're against
the purebred you think you people should
just get rescues
probably but they're they're losers
the rescues i mean let's be very honest
well
they're and you don't want them around
your children because many of them will
attack your children
that's true this is true if they were
beaten
and they were homeless and you know then
yeah no good
i think they should make up lies about
where the dogs were because the woman
was like we don't know where this dog
came from like just make it up
just make up a lie about where it came
from that makes me want to adopt this
dog right
but i want a like a purebred puppy
that's from a breeder
who's you know i get it
i totally get it they they have a lot of
problems they don't live very long
the purebred yeah yeah perfect
that probably describes me i want
a a dog that i can
have fun with for a few years and then
i mean how long is your three-legged do
you have a three-legged dog how old is
it
emma is nine now yeah she's old isn't
that insane
yeah i think she'll live until she's
like 13. but that's absurd
yeah to me i get a purebred st bernard
eight years
i'm just saying i'm not trying to you
know
i just really want a dog but i don't
want to really take care of it and i
don't want
one of these mixed breed homeless
baby killers which is
rescue dogs i believe are
homeless baby killers of
of uncertain origin and i'm just
wondering why you'd bring that into your
home
i don't know i know adoptions are way up
during covets that's been good less
animals going to kill shelters what is
the kill shelter i find this interesting
i believe there's a certain amount of
time the dog can be in one of these
shelters before then it just gets
executed
so if no one wants it after a certain
amount of time they got to make room for
more
and then it's just gone it's a dark job
yeah working in a dog kill shelter
yeah who does that
god that's tough that is tough that's a
tough job
yeah i still don't want the rescues in
my home
even though it is a tough job i still
think that
is it is it should we and i'm not trying
again should we maybe outlaw
rescuing dogs
[Laughter]
because it's too much of a risk do you
know what i mean
in terms of it killing people and babies
yeah and just not not looking
good and everything should we maybe
not allow people to adopt
should they go right to the kill shelter
i might ask ask questions i don't really
know you're more of a dog person i love
dogs
but i just want to understand the way
this is all supposed to work
so if your dog gets lost and animal
control gets it it should just go right
to the kill shelter
essentially wow i mean loss is
interesting i mean it has information
on it it can be returned if it has a
chip in it they scan it well but it does
have a
does it have a collar where it says it's
going yeah yeah yeah okay so why would
they do
you don't need to put that dog in a kill
shot you could return it to its owner
yeah animal control takes it to an
animal shelter and then
calls you and says you have to pick it
up and you have to pay money to get it
out
i've done that before okay well that
then that dog clearly doesn't have to go
to a kill shelter right
but any dog that gets lost without a
collar or a chip should go to the kill
shelter
is what you're saying i'm saying this
this is what i'm saying yeah
i think dogs
that haven't made the right choices
should have to take responsibility
i'm not i'm saying
when you're rescuing a dog you're
adopting
a homeless
mentally ill baby killer and you're
bringing it into your home
when you go to a breeder and you get a
purebred animal
you're getting a dog of with has a
lineage
maybe their mother or father was a show
dog and you spend money
you spend thousands of dollars and when
you spend thousands of dollars on
something it's
better and you take it more seriously
right yeah it's a good point so i think
the problem is the animal shelters are
actually the problem
because they allow the reason that you
have homeless dogs is because you have
animal shelters
[Laughter]
do you understand what dude let's walk
this out
homeless i swear i don't see a flaw here
i really don't you got this whole
thriving business of people
selling homeless pets they're slinging
homeless dog go with me on this folks
they got these people in the shelters
slinging these drug mules
that they find wandering around parking
lots shut it down
shut it down yes or yes shut it down
have the only people that should get
dogs are people who can afford
to pay thousands of dollars to a breeder
for a purebred and yes it has health
problems
but that's also good
to assess how serious you are about
owning a dog because yes you're gonna
get a purebred dog and you're gonna have
to take it to the hospital
all the time and that means you're
serious about owning a dog
if you go adopt a homeless baby killer
from one of these
uh you know one of these [__] animal
drug mule
animal shelters you're like okay i just
have this
and then what it's going to become a man
again yeah
true i just am against rescuing dogs
i've always been against it
i don't know why that's a controversial
position
it seems like it is propping up a
system
that is really terrible
for both the animals and the people
why are these all these stray dogs
around
why because
of the whole the homeless dog shelter
that makes money they get money from the
state these people
that's true the humane society they get
money from the state
and dog and cats i'm including cats
should never be
cats should survive on the streets yeah
they should never be taken into a
shelter i agree
cats are capable they were gods cats
were gods
at one time in egypt true
and now they're taken into these
shelters it's
not right i don't think it's right i
think if you want a dog you should take
it seriously
and not rescue a dog and go to a
go to a breeder and deal with a breeder
if you
if you actually take it seriously
i believe if you rescue a dog it says
something negative
about you you have a god complex
[Laughter]
you wanna you're trying to [__] it
you're maybe trying to [__] the animal
is that what you're trying to do
supposedly a lot of people are
you said that you said you didn't you
say that a lot of people trying to [__]
lizards now
how do you find these things you said
people trying to [__] anacondas
uh snakes yeah there was a video that
went viral on twitter a couple years ago
of a guy
going at it with a snake in the egg hole
like just holding it up like that be
honest was it hot
no it was strange it was bizarre but you
can't not you can't look away
you it's if it's a 10-second thing you
watch it you know
there's one on twitter of a guy having
sex with a fish too like a carp
that went kind of viral how often do you
watch people have sex with animals
i mean those are really like the two
times so you've
stumbled upon stumbled upon yeah
i've never played them on the show no we
can't why
we'd get thrown off youtube for playing
a man having sex with a carp
it's bestiality
indeed interesting
that does seem like we would we would be
removed
but how funny would it be removed like
you're just in a room of canceled people
and they're like how did you how did you
get de-platformed some guy's like hey
man i just tweeted a lot of q and on
[__]
another guy's like you know i just was
retweeting all these crazy accounts or
making racist jokes and
i'm like bestiality
the old-fashioned way watching a guy
[__] a snake
but it fascinates you when people have
sex with things they're not supposed to
yeah it is interesting it's odd
something went wrong in that guy's head
yeah wires got crossed something
happened but do you not understand that
those are the type of people that are
rescuing dogs
those people it's kind of true
absolutely is true yeah
all the people that work in the shelter
were sick people
um let's be very honest i kid a lot
about this
on i kid around a lot here because i'm a
comedian but i'm not kidding around
about this
i think if you rescue a dog
you are you are engaging in
bestiality what is the name for
somebody who engages in bestiality
let me see see if there's a singular
what what is the name for somebody
someone
who engages in bestiality
um let's see now we're on reddit so god
help us
oh zoophile zoo file yeah
your zoo file
what a horrible lesson to teach your
children taking them to a homeless
shelter
to adopt some mutt what a horrible
lesson
to teach your children to say we're
gonna go to the
shelter and pick up some dirty rat
to bring home what a beautiful lesson to
go to a breeder
and see a bunch of puppies in a field
and say i'm
spending a lot of [__] money for this
dog
you better [__] knock it out of the
park with the
with the uh kill with the um homeless
shelter the
animal shelters it's easy come easy go
easy come easy go that's why they bring
these things back
because it's easy come easy go dogs
should cost thousands of dollars
um they should
get mad at me if you want but if you
have a dog
and you're young you're not serious
about succeeding it if you really want
to succeed and you have a very difficult
career
and you have a dog and you've adopted a
dog i know you're not serious about
succeeding
truth just a reality i know people that
are
sweet people but they go i have a dog
and it depends on what your career is
but
if you really want to light the world on
fire you're really trying to do well
and you have decided that it's more
important to have a dog
um you know you're you're not you're
letting things get in your way
you're letting things get in your way
which is fine but just
admit that to yourself so many people i
talk to like man i want to do this i
want to do that but then they have a dog
and i'm like dude you have a dog
that's crazy you you weigh yourself down
with things like that and it just shows
that you don't have a
um
you don't understand that time is so
valuable that's the problem you just
can't be you know
so i had
six dogs before i did the rogan show
and i and i afterwards it went well and
i took them all to a kill shelter
four of them went to kill shelter two of
them i drowned in the bathtub myself
just because i then started selling
tickets and i needed to
you understand i mean
massive massive's flagship product the
smash and greens
are an extremely nutrient-dense blend of
organic superfoods with no fillers
the ingredients were all specifically
chosen to maximize micronutrients
carb hunger curb hunger sorry maximize
energy
clear skin and burn fat usda
certified organic loaded with extremely
nutrient-dense superfoods
three times more dense formula than any
other superfoods blend on the market
can be used as a meal replacement or in
fasting routines
or take it as a daily supplement mitch
aguiar
is a navy seal of 10 years and current
mma fighter
he created smash and greens as a way to
cut down in weight class for
professional fights
besides founding massive he also created
adopt a cop
bjj which is a non
what which is a non-profit charity
which pays for police officers jiu jitsu
training
to create better trained police who
don't instinctively turn to deadly force
well that's nice that made a turn i
didn't think it was
gonna make adopt a cop i thought it was
like we need a deadly
force of fighters on the street these
cops need to be able to break next cobra
kai forever
but uh very smart he's getting cops that
are
good in jiu jitsu so they don't have to
put people in like wwf wrestling holes
and
and snap their necks they also have fun
shirts with inspirational quotes such as
beat it nerd and don't be a [__] and
defund the media
i like that one send me that see if you
have what it takes to complete their 10
day fasting smash and greens integrity
and accountability challenge
lose 25 pounds and earn 500 cash i'll do
that
all you have to lose is wait visit mask
massive
supplements dot com that's m a s f
supplements.com
for details you could also use the promo
code timd for 10
off all orders and across the site don't
be a [__] mindset is everything that's
massive supplements dot com
massivesupplements.com promo code
t-i-m-d
you get 10 off your order i may do the
challenge
i mean think about it i may do the
challenge all right thank you
how do you choose which internet
provider to use for me it's easy i don't
have internet in the house i pay for so
i don't use any of them the sad thing
most of us have very little choice
because isps operate like monopolies in
the regions they serve
then they use this monopoly power to
take advantage of customers data caps
streaming throttles the list goes
on but worst of all many isps log your
internet activity and sell that data to
other big tech companies or advertisers
to present
to prevent isps from seeing my internet
activity i protect all my devices
with expressvpn it's a simple app for
your computer a smartphone that encrypts
all of your network data
and tells it through a secure vpn server
everyone needs this right now
we've got a crazy totalitarian
government big tech oligarchs we got uh
but the
companies are coming and getting y'all
they're gonna get you good
you got the nsa and this chase manhattan
and everybody in between
they all want to get you they want to
find out what you're googling and sell
it to you shove it right down your
gullet
so go to expressvpn to really help
yourself and your goddamn
family expressvpn does all this without
slowing your connection
that's why it's rated number one vpn
service by cnet
and wired everyone loves expressvpn so
if you go to expressvpn.com
tim dillon you get three extra months
free that's [__] absurd
90 days of free vpn you need a virtual
private network it is smart
it is it is it is thoughtful in this
climate
you have one right yes i use it vpn.com
tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-o-n that's
expressvpn e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
tim dylan to get three extra months free
we're moving again just update everybody
we're moving we're being robbed
ben doesn't live with me but he kind of
died i mean he's here every day
but we're we're being robbed by the
people
that we're not supposed to that we're
supposed to not rob us
i'm in a house there's a back house the
landlord's daughter lives in the back
house
they have one meter for utilities i'm
paying the utilities
apparently for his daughter who's got
blue hair
at the end of the day it's not right
we don't have wi-fi for 10 days that's
how we do our job
no wi-fi for 10 days dishwasher doesn't
work two months
daughter's got wi-fi we're paying for it
she doesn't have it she has it okay
i uh then then the landlord who's like a
bumpkin
i live in a part of california where
it's like fake cowboys
i'm leaving here anyway so i'll say what
it is called agora hills
and it's like fake these people all work
it like they worked at like paramount
and then they resigned or got fired and
now they have ranches and they pretend
to be cowboys
it's embarrassing for all involved
and uh yeah they're like fake cowboys
they're like geared her up i'm like you
have a tesla shut up
i'm like dude you like you managed the
spice girls
you're you're not john wayne but they
walk around here like
it's like rodeo country it's time to get
out of here
i've been here what two months yeah time
to leave
time to go and again we're not mad it's
not a war when it's not contentious
there's a little i'm not thrilled but
tell the story about what happened with
the with the this gentleman who owns the
property's friend
why do you get nervous what can we
legally talk about are we
we're we're in the clear here i can
legally talk about my truth i have a
highly i have sharky lawyers
okay do you know my lawyer i do yeah
sal cohen title baum
berkowitz ariel sharon
benjamin netanyahu berg
that's the name of my lawyer
bring it i mean we're talking about our
experience we're telling our truth
okay this is the truth of what happened
they're probably going to hear this
right
i don't know what they do it's not my
concern
i i'm speaking my truth as someone who i
feel was
taken advantage of dishonestly you did
not disclose
that there weren't two meters you have
one meter for the utilities it is not
right
you didn't disclose your daughter was
living in the back house you said a
property manager was living there it's
not a property manager it's just a
rental
it's not a caretaker um
you've not fixed any of the appliances
these these are this is wrong because
i have like a business manager and
because i'm in a you know i live i'm an
entertainment business like
we all have business managers because we
all don't know anything about money
right
so we perform in all these different
states and unless we get somebody to
help us out we end up [__] going to
jail
wesley snipes whatever so they think
they're just gonna like
send bills to the business manager and
i'm never gonna question it obviously
they think i'm like a drug addict or
something you know because of my
you know i don't know appearance and
actions but i'm actually quite sober and
quite on top of things so
please tell the people the story because
i
i want everyone we should be as open and
honest on this show
as as humanly possible sure so we're not
knocking anyone here
there's things i like about agora hills
uncle af's sandwiches
really good sushi raku so good the best
that's it it's a good bell good taco
bell
these people walk down the street it is
a great belt but the people walk down
the street here riding horses can you
stop
with the horses you cut it out get
another hobby
stop pretending you're a [__] ranch
hand
you made all your [__] money working
at like united artists
and then you retired because you locked
a secretary in a room
so they're like let's go and now you're
like you know
get up and it's time to get on up
let's cut it out so tell tell everyone
what happened because people trust you
more than they trust me
okay literally what happened is you know
you they were sensing you were unhappy
with not having internet
for a week and you finally really pushed
back on it
so landlord calls me and says hey my
friend is in i.t
i know spectrum can't come out for a
while but how about i send him over to
help you out
i don't talk to anyone by the way ben
talks to everyone he's
great at it the reason i don't talk to
people is because i say things that can
be construed
as threats even though i'm kidding
so i joke around all the time about
things and i don't speak to people
because when i make a joke
people tend to believe their family has
been threatened
but it is a bit i'm making a joke
i'm not going to kill anyone if i say as
a joke i know where
blank sleeps you go hey that's
that's not cool i'm making a i'm joking
a comedian
but i just say things like that because
they're fun and they they they
rile people up so when i i like to rile
people up
that i've been uh not
nice
so uh yeah so if he
he's like i'm gonna send my friend over
who's in i.t just to help you guys out
fine i assume no charge of course
we would have hired our own i.t guys the
friend did nothing by the way
my friend did nothing except tell us how
he bought seven houses
during the mortgage crisis and went
belly up
i said i wish i met you 10 years ago you
[__]
so he like you know just troubleshoots
everything i know how to do he knows
where the line's coming in the house
resets the modem blah blah blah nothing
works like i told him it would
um and then when spectrum comes out the
landlord calls me again and goes hey i
want my it guy there just to help cover
just so we have an extra set of eyes on
things he goes i know you're tech savvy
but
we'll have an extra set of eyes on
things i'm like okay i appreciate that
blank
thank you that's very nice he comes over
and falls around the spectrum guy for
seven hours
and just really just annoys him he goes
oh it's this and spectrum guy goes no
that goes up to the dish satellite
that's not some guy was so
tired of having this [__] guy follow
him around and i get it yeah
super annoyed so then after everything
said and done the next day
our business manager calls us and goes
hey we just got a bill for
fifteen hundred dollars fifteen hundred
dollars
absurd shame
i was pissed yeah you were pissed and i
was pissed and i i mean i'm not getting
super angry i just wanna
dissolve this because it's not worked
out and it's unfortunate
um but now i'm starting to realize that
like
this was always the plan was to kind of
rip me off and just try to send bills to
the business manager that he would pay
maybe not even tell me about it i'm sure
that works and apparently that happens a
lot and
i am sure it does because there's people
asleep at the switch
but i'm trying to you know stay on top
of things and i just was very
and you know the first thing when i
moved in they're like if you have a dog
you can bring a dog dogs are okay and
it's like oh here we go again
pet people pet people
[__] you over
not shocked but we're moving on
we don't know where yet stay in
california for now
yeah i'm not mad anymore i'm not angry
no one's angry no one's angry
no one's angry it just is unfortunate
that
there's you know i i feel like i have
not been dealt with fairly
you know
we tried to change the wi-fi once and
then he goes my daughter can't miss her
fashion school
yeah it's like oh oh that's fake sir
fashion school is fake
she's not going to be ralph lauren
she's wasting her time tell her to come
in and fix the wi-fi
please so we're moving on again
we're moving on again i'm a rolling
stone wherever i lay my hat is my home
energy to wrap the episode up
no will will towards my aunt
remember yesterday no will will towards
my aunt
i wish her the best i truly do
i was disappointed with the comment
which i couldn't find maybe she deleted
it
i think so i couldn't find we have it
screenshotted in case she tries to
but you know i mean listen i i i wish
her the best and i
this show's not an angry show we're
having fun with everybody and i know
that some people
she you know people are gonna hear that
and inevitably they're gonna
you know think that it's you know she's
gonna hear that and she'll probably get
offended by it
but that's not my intention so if she
was offended by anything i said i'm
sorry i apologize i mean it'd say
fair is fair i i just
wanted to get some things off my chest i
felt it was rather mild
i felt the indictment of her was rather
mild
and i hope that we can still break bread
in the future
but i might need a new family i imagine
after this comes out in a few hours
because it's saturday
at four i assume when this comes out
by sunday night i've heard from people
but i don't answer my phone so i don't
care
by sunday night i imagine people are
a little
you know but we got to make the show fun
and we got to be honest
and we did those two things we did those
two things
we're gonna wrap it up louis ck thinks
the show's too long he goes it's really
funny but i think it's too long it's
like
hey man you don't have to listen
you know you're a busy guy you don't
have to listen
so just anyone that gives me advice ever
i don't take the advice of legends
so just realize that so yeah i'm not
gonna take your advice
i'm like okay he said you know he
envisions it to be shorter and more
compact
but we we like going long and uh people
like it the fans like it so no one's at
no one is at gunpoint that has to listen
to this so
there's the good news by the way
but we love louie and think he's a
genius and everything he's just he's
wrong about this
because people can be wrong legends can
be wrong
you know sorry that's all right
it's the way it is see i never spend it
spends like i don't wanna
who cares who cares stop
folks really you get like three friends
in life everyone else
who really gives a [__] like let's be
very honest
legend family who really gives a [__]
meet people that you have a ton of
respect for
you won't care if five minutes into it
you go
that's the funny thing about life it
just doesn't matter
you're gonna get a few friends that's it
so you can live where you want to live
and get involved in the community
and liberty blue and climb the corporate
ladder or get
you know and then none of it'll ever
matter because
you know you suck i suck and everyone
sucks
nothing good out there and there ain't
nothing good coming
so that's all
we wish everyone the best
we're gonna release the special version
of the show for louis it's gonna be a
minute
it's gonna be a quick minute gonna be
sped up
if you think the show's too long you can
also listen to it uh at three times the
speed
which is right yeah you can or you know
i run the tim dillon show clips channel
too if that's more your speed
watch the show don't watch the clips i
mean you can watch the clips too
but that's okay but i mean you know that
that's why nothing really you just you
just you breeze in and out you know the
house doesn't work you go somewhere else
you figure it out the job sucks the
girlfriend sucks the boyfriend sucks
whatever it is you're dead you have age
you have cancer it's all the same it
doesn't matter it's all the same
just don't ever ever under any
circumstances
hire my aunt as a [__] lawyer or
rescue
a dog and if you're to rescue someone
and you want to rescue a dog
rescue my aunt because she is a dog